we're here to talk about I can't believe
I meant to say it but we're here to talk
about grand theft auto 5 on PC
Rob handler it feels like it's been
decades for everything for the PC
version GTA 5 s come out came out today
Kimi yesterday yeah myself and Mary
played a bunch of it on the livestream
yesterday that's right first of all what
are your thoughts on it in terms of e
let's get into the graphical pry way
sure because that's probably the one
thing the everyone's been looking
forward to but all these screenshots of
one not right here's a look so it looks
pretty good I mean granted
everyone's systems gonna be different we
played on GTX 760 and we didn't get as
much optimization as we liked just
because we rushed right into a stream
yeah Mary you were saying yesterday on
the stream that it didn't look that much
different like the console versions I
mean we were playing around we messed
with some things we tried to get
character differentiation like more we
wanted more people we wanted the
population and we wanted more diverse
population and so we did that by
security and then we walked around
punching people looking to see if there
was anyone the same look different but
so it's not it's not like a huge
difference from consoles what I was
saying and it's not that it looked bad I
mean it looks fantastic and there's
things are you're naturally going to
notice you know I think like the draw
distance is bigger and better I think
the lighting looks better but it wasn't
a huge difference I like you said
they're like sliders for like density in
terms of pedestrians in terms of like oh
it like traffic as well for distance so
and one of the big ones was I wasn't
actually just recently tweaked with it a
little more to see if I could get more
out of it because we were playing on it
just normal texture quality right and
you could really tell it wasn't
comparable to the Xbox one or ps4 it
like it looked it looked like an older
gen
so you crank that up so I cranked right
is there's something also called like
population variety right so I crank that
like pretty much all the way to zero
right just white guys right look like
Congress
and was able to get more memory out of
like the graphical quality so then I
could then crank it up to like high and
get basically what you would expect out
of like an Xbox one cool and rig you
usually know is if I get is it taking up
quite a lot of memory I know they have a
slider showing you how much your video
remember you've got left right which is
great and that's how you can do like you
know just a lot of tweaking and kind of
get what you know what you're actually
walking into so yeah that was g TX 760
where 2 980 s yeah in the back 4k oh
cool and so people have been messing
around with that and have been able to
crank that up like all the way how does
that look
yeah pretty great times the framerate
you trying to aim for 64 the graphics
yeah they were tweaking like doing like
my artwork tweaks and stuff it looks it
seems like 60 yeah I mean at least you
know 50 or 60 yeah and the difference
especially like that it's all depending
on what you're doing right you know like
60 while you're driving is gonna make a
hell of a difference it looks so much
better and you know when you look at the
draw distance you don't like if you're
in a field in a forest or something like
that that's like when that stuff is
gonna really shine and we're really
gonna City it wasn't as amazing I think
just in the next few rounds we're gonna
play and the open is really when you're
gonna start seeing how beautiful that
game can really be actually she looks
good though yeah not anymore apparently
apart from the graphics stuff then and
obviously they've added a bunch of stuff
to the the director whatnot we'll get
tonight a second but I'm gonna talk to
you better something you touched on
earlier Rob which was the PC obviously
now you can use a massive keyboard right
how does that change how you sort of
play with this world because one of the
problems with first-person on the ps4
and Xbox one was that you were playing
it like you play a first-person shooter
sure you're yeah so you're especially
the driving or like operating a vehicle
if you're trying to look around you're
constantly trying to fight the stick
automatically trying to Center
yeah and that is is a little frustrating
for first-person like if you're driving
you wanna look up that you're you know
out the window to the left
you're constantly kind of battling in on
the stick you're saying on the I'm sorry
for consoles yeah so now you got ya
mouse and keyboard
and you just get complete freedom and
that feels awesome feel like you're just
been around a good FPS yeah like
first-person like shooting like oh my
god it felt really great cuz when I
playing console I'm I'm actually kind of
constantly going back and forth yeah
like maybe I like to drive third-person
that seems like a common thing and the
house yeah have the options in there for
like defaulting to third-person when
you're driving right first-person well
how is it driving and first-person with
the mouse stuff it's it's a little back
and forth cuz I mean a and D Keys for
driving is always gonna be a little odd
like I always prefer a controller for
driving but then again yeah I could now
one of the main complaints with the
first person driving was that your your
field of view is so slim even with it
cranked all the way up it's not as much
as you like but now like I said you can
just use the mouse and you can look
around much more freely and it and it
feels significantly better I guess the
problem as well is that we're using
accelerator and the brake
you can like throttle them I mean you
can't on a PC because they're just
binary inputs you're anything stopping
you from just hopping like your
controller off to one side and like
doing this and keyboard so that's what's
really great it is like yeah you can
literally just have your controller off
to the right and just pick that up and
it'll immediately switch back and forth
and that's gonna go the same for I
haven't done yet I can't wait which is
like joystick or I mean I think maybe we
have hopefully a driving Cyril assess
steering wheel around this would be cool
to see if that row that's where the fuss
car there's clearly 60 friends out there
like it looks good
is that just regular gameplay it looks
like it's sped up Oh guys that's
gameplay this real haulin ass it's just
tight that's high playing - it looks so
different
60 frames a second Jesus yeah much of
this is coming across on the livestream
it you know depending where you're
connected so actually and this was the
system we used yesterday for the stream
but I had just tweaked this so now we
have this would be high settings on
texture is always just beating all just
random directors in the aqueduct you can
really see all the detail in their faces
of their age and all the [ __ ] they've
been through and their sequences and
they beat them nice work by another
element then you guys did a video on
last week is the
Kermode and the sort of all this crazy
machinima stuff right and get involved
in can you do that right off the bat
what's up do you think a lot of people
gonna be using that like it seems like
it kind of a neat little feature for
like people to put up cool to YouTube
videos but like well the people have
like a compulsion to just make their own
weird I think a good amount of people
I'm personally one of them like
immediately just like you found yourself
we did the stream yesterday and next and
I'm like this is owning out Kenny lost
into like making your own video changing
the camera angle and such it's something
that has a little bit of a learning
curve we noticed right away you know he
was just pushing all these buttons and I
was like I have no idea what you're
doing right now you're it turns out
neither of us knew we were talking about
but you you know you you learn I think
it's the kind of thing where you're
gonna spend you know four or five hours
just kind of getting into it figuring
out what it is you actually want to make
this is us kind of tinkering with it for
the very first time yesterday and it's
interesting you you make these little
pub more pieces the markers in the in
the footage that you've captured and
then for each of those markers you have
just so many options from what angle you
want if you want it slowed down if you
want to put an Instagram filter on there
and it was so good like we were looking
for people were like well how do we get
the angle just right under how you
clipped that woman's ankle right and
flipped her over six times a night but I
mean it went so fast I think we spent 40
minutes easily on a on a 20 second clip
and it's not even a great clip this is
our final product yeah so we have it
slowed down here and then Instagram
filter that filters called Normandy I
think the exciting thing about that is
not like any creation suite right like
even if you are don't feel like spending
the four hours or you do and you make a
dumb clip and you're like well that was
fun I'm done with that forever I there
are people out there that are gonna make
incredible things just because the tool
is so neat and I think one of the
fascinating things about it that always
stands out to me is how you can pick
like any person like any perspective
within a certain area you can have a
bystander you can have a security camera
you can have a bird yeah like you can
and because the thing like the one of
things I was love about GTA is trying to
drive with cinematic camera you on but I
think it's gonna be a incredible will
see an incredible boon of machinima type
staff coming out we're gonna have like
movie trailers done in GTA for the next
like [ __ ] four years oh yeah yeah
absolutely you're gonna see stuff that
has nothing to do with GTA either which
i think is always fascinating like we
loved watching that with old GTA videos
like there's like GTA 4 videos people
who are like having their own sets of
problems it's like an episode of 90210
in GTA's world and that's like my
favorite stuff like you don't have to be
in the world of low Sun so it's like
take me somewhere else yeah you know
like go full Garry's Mod like all the
GTA san andreas were not like mod scene
bursts open that was like all just from
people breaking the game apart and then
there were people just making their own
cities and stuff right like that'd be
really cool if we had like city skyline
type mods coming out for GTA and oh
here's a new city that's one of them
another one of the most exciting things
about having a PC mods which is an
unquantifiable at this point but history
tells us anything like we're gonna see
some cool [ __ ] yeah right you guys are
obviously very excited for this I want
to hear Chris you've played GTA on the
old platform short do you have any like
impetus to go back and play this on PC
this is cuz it's been like the 2013 game
you know it's been a while like I didn't
beat the campaign of GTA 5 I played a
little bit of online I was tempted to
get back into heists when I saw you guys
eventually all have eventually worked
out I quit nine months later yeah like
just that time invent like I enjoy GTA
but I'm not it's not enticing me back I
mean there's a lot of other games coming
up and in terms of like big open world
things spend a lot of time in I mean The
Witcher is like a monkey yeah you know
so like it's not gonna touch me back but
I will click on a hell of GTA videos and
watch that really great all right we're
gonna have that Geralt of Rivia mod for
GTA 5 coming at any day now that's grand
theft auto 5 on PC finally there was a
time there when we didn't know if it was
actually gonna be released on PC but
it's out now you can pick it up yourself
the review for GTA 5 on PC will be on
kake.com later this week and it should
make sure you check that out soon